et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
patrick anr bonjour merci jour d'être
avec mon sénateur du nord président du
groupe socialiste ici au cdh en
détention pendant venu dans une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représenté par creissels
bertron du groupe la dépêche bonjour
cristal quand j'aurai à nouveau show
patrick kane bonjour vous et patrick
année on va évidemment parler de la
situation de la gauche dans quelques
instants mais d'abord l'actualité
emmanuel macron a prononcé lundi soir
lundi dans la journée par dans un
discours sur l'europe dans lequel il
plaide pour la réforme et notamment sur
la question des traités qu'il veut
réviser il souhaite également une
communauté politique européenne qui peut
que pourrait notamment intégrer le
royaume uni ou encore l'ukraine il
relance une idée de françois mitterrand
c'était en 89 vous soutenez la volonté
du chef de l'état sur cette réforme de
l'europe oui quand quand il évoque la
notion de fête de confédération c'était
le mot qui avait utilisé par françois
mitterrand il est dans le sens de
l'histoire c'est à dire une capacité à
s'élargir mais qui ne doit pas cacher la
volonté aussi d'approfondir c'est
compliqué c'est de dire il faut
permettre je pense aux états des balkans
qui depuis longtemps sont demandeurs on
le sait bien c'est l'albanie la
macédoine du nord le monténégro la
serbie n'oublions pas aussi la turquie
aussi dans cette démarche d'adhésion
c'est un peu plus compliqué on a
aujourd'hui d'autres états et en
particulier l'ukraine qui mérite notre
attention et qui quelque part cette
attention veulent aussi notre protection
cette protection collective pour une
paix totalement assumée et une paix
organisée vis-à-vis
deux pays agresseur est aujourd'hui la
russie est un pays agresseur non je suis
favorable après c'est un objet politique
non identifié alors quand même lui
donner du sens et du contenu quelles
compétences pourquoi faire ça ce voit là
on est pour l'instant sur les grandes de
je dirais les grandes annonces
je suis un socialiste européen il fait
une autre proposition importante qui est
de généraliser les votent à la majorité
qualifiée
1 pour éviter les blocages créé par
l'unanimité ce que cette ce changement
là vous y seriez favorable oui c'est le
l'europe aujourd'hui sur un peu
démocratique est arrivé au bout de la
démarche il ya un équilibre qui a été
trouvée dans les différents traités avec
le poids de la commission parce qu'avant
la commission était omniprésente omni
puissante le parlement a aujourd'hui un
peu plus de deux poids mais il y fit si
on veut une europe démocratique il faut
qu'elles puissent évoluer dans les votes
émis par les parlementaires donc ça va
dans le bon sens je ne suis pas étonné
qu emmanuel macron que je connais et
j'ai eu comme collègue hôpitaux lui même
comme collègue au conseil des ministres
il a toujours été un européen convaincu
et est ailleurs il a marqué des points
dans sa campagne présidentielle en
montrant que lui était quand même sur
des bases fondamentalement européenne
par rapport à ses concurrents
oui on voit que la tension est de plus
en plus forte qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui pour aider encore plus
l'ukraine est ce que on peut aller
jusqu'où on peut aller dans le dans le
train des sanctions qu'est-ce que sa
ligne de crête les sanctions économiques
on le voit bien n'entraîne pas
un retrait aujourd'hui des russes et
notamment dans les classes pour vous
elles sont efficaces mais la force de
résilience rue c'était terrible wihr
voilà ça c'est ce les russes l'économie
russe a des réserves qui nous permettent
de tenir combien de temps personne ne le
sait c'est une course contre la montre
qu'on peut faire de plus aujourd'hui
alors sur le plan des sanctions une fois
les jusqu'au bout moi je suis favorable
à ce qu'on arrête les importations
et je sais très bien les conséquences
que ça veut dire pour nous en termes
notamment des restrictions de pouvoir
d'achat de web de restriction au début
du conflit j'avais dit mais finalement
se chauffer un degré de moins pour
permettre aux ukrainiens de garder la
liberté je crois que ça l'est forts que
nous pouvons penser que les français
sont prêts aujourd'hui oui sachant que
willy fowler est question du pouvoir
d'achat extrêmement sensible alors sur
le pouvoir d'achat les français ne s'y
sont pas prêts je vous le dis comme je
le pense est née la réponse politique du
gouvernement ne me paraît pas
satisfaisante
n'importe politique du gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'est mais ne vous inquiétez
pas je serai là je vous donne des primes
prime inflation
prime alimentation qui devrait arrimer
pendant l'été la prime macron
défiscaliser désocialisés enfin une clé
manoir bois de largeur noir très
concrètement
à quoi il promet une loi exceptionnelle
de pouvoir d'achat pour l'été dès la
reprise du jeu avec notamment
l'indexation de l'inflation des
retraites sur l'inflation dans le chef
du dint projet de loi de finances
rectificative ce sont des
cons les voir les fois qu'on en débatte
et qu'on ait du temps pour en débattre
cette fois ci j'ai entendu le président
nous dira mais le parlement sera mieux
respectés très bien c'était un aveu
quand même qu'ils n'étaient pas tout à
fait respecté notamment au travers des
ordonnances qui étaient multipliées donc
moi je souhaite que cette loi que nous
allons à améliorer en termes de
propositions puissent intervenir au plus
vite parce que les français n'en peuvent
plus
l'ukraine a été évoquée il ya des
conséquences mais l'ukraine n'explique
pas tout ça fait cinq ans de
gouvernement ou le leu l'exécutif impose
aux français des sacrifices
extraordinaires en augmentant les
inégalités entre ceux qui ont le plus
riches les plus aisés et les plus
modestes
pas toujours pauvre modeste la ddc
impôts je parle d'un système qui fait
que monsieur macron veut être le
champion du monde de la baisse des
impôts et le champion olympique des
primes
pour les français ça c'est ce que
veulent les français c'est pas l'aumône
ce qu'ils veulent c'est avoir un pouvoir
d'achat liée à leur travail et pour ça
il faut augmenter les salaires moi
j'aimerais j'aurais aimé que monsieur mc
ren annonce non seulement ces primes et
de l'indexation mais indexation qui peut
y être content quand on ya une inflation
à 4 ou 5 % par contre par contre une
grande conférence salariale comme ça a
été le cas au début du quinquennat de
françois hollande aujourd'hui répondrai
je crois aux besoins des français les
français veulent pouvoir vivre
correctement de leur travail pour
revenir à l'ukraine rarement la question
l'ukraine allait être un peu mis sous le
tapis dans l'accord entre le ps et la
france insoumise un bon prétexte que
l'ukraine c'est le domaine réservé du
chef de l'état que le sait accor vise à
être un accord de gouvernement
pourraient être premier ministre est-ce
que ça reste un problème la question de
crédit actuelles comme et la france à
laquelle comeau dans l'accord mais vous
savez un accord c'est un compromis donc
par définition ceux qui ont rédigé cet
accord des deux parties ont essayé de
trouver les mots qui plaisent à chacun
bon
en tout cas historiquement ne l'avons
pas la même position vous monsieur
mélenchon sur l'ukraine ces quelques
mots qui sont insuffisants selon vous
dans cet accord oui parce que j'aurais
aimé qu'on soit plus clair sur la
livraison d'armes
à l'ukraine ça n'a pas été le cas et on
connaît la position de monsieur
mélenchon qui a été exprimée qui sait un
toit sous la fin à soupe liens depuis
mai il avait dit au moment du débat sur
l'ukraine au début du conflit qui avait
été organisée par l'exécutif tant à
l'assemblée qu'au sénat il est midi mais
il ne faut pas livré d'armes à l'ukraine
parce que finalement n'est pas sûr qu'il
y ait des résistants ukrainien puisse
gagner bon c'est ça ferait donné combien
déjà
mais nous sommes déjà déco belligérants
de fait mais nous sommes pas engagés
dans une guerre où la hausse il n'a pas
déclaré la guerre et pour vous on est
des cons belligérants arrive le drian
dit on n'est pas des communes gérant n'a
pas de biens dits l'écho belligérants de
fait en fournissant des armes mais nous
n'avons pas déclaré la guerre
aux belligérants officiellement c'est
être une déclaration de guerre ce n'est
pas le cas ni du côté russe on hier un
petit peu cynique ni du côté européen
par contre aidées les ukrainiens à
pouvoir défendre leur territoire y
compris quand on leur annonce qu'ils
pourraient demain devenir des membres de
la communauté politique européenne que
nous avons évoqué au début notre
entretien et il faut être cohérent et là
nous n'avons pas la même position avec l
efi et jean luc mélenchon en particulier
voilà votre var si le parti socialiste a
passé un accord avec la france insoumise
et europe ecologie les verts
qu'est ce qui vous gêne vous dans cet
accord vous n'avez pas l'air d'être très
favorable mais vous n'êtes pas encore
vraiment exprimé sur aux jeux sont là je
me suis exprimée dès le début en dix ans
en disant je ne voulais pas de
ralliements
aliments iman mais en tout cas
ralliement la corde au cou la robe de
bure auprès de monsieur mélenchon non
non non j'ai l'accord sur le fond
d'accord sur le fond a permis aux
socialistes d'évoquer des sujets qui
peuvent fâcher entre nous la laïcité
quelle conception de site et l'école
l'international l'europe où on a mis
j'ai envie de dire des remparts par
rapport à d'autres positions qui étaient
celles de et les filles et elle est
finie l'a acceptée est ce que l efi nous
l'a acceptée par opportunisme ou par
conviction c'est l'histoire qui nous le
dira si demain monsieur blanche en
devenait premier ministre de notre pays
donc
je dis savez quand on négocie un accord
ont fait un pas l'un vers l'autre est-ce
que c'est nous qui avons fait plus de
pas vers monsieur mélenchon monsieur
lanchon envers nous en tout cas il ya un
accord qui est signé et qui a été validé
par le parti socialiste je le dis très
simplement cet accord juste et fondée je
suis socialiste mon le parlement du
parti au travers de son conseil national
a validé ces l'accord il m'engage
puisque je suis membre du parti
socialiste à partir de là c'est accor
naturellement n'a de sens que si il y à
une majorité de gauche qui se prépare
pour la prochaine législature
je vois bien les sondages ça va être
compliqué
[Musique]
après midi il ya cinq semaines de
campagne si la gauche démagogique
majoritaire l'accord prévoit qu'il
devienne premier ministre mais je pense
qu'il ya encore beaucoup de chemin à
accomplir pour pouvoir y parvenir
je la gauche va tenter d'être
majoritaires mais comme la macro ni va
tenter d'être majoritaires ou comme une
peine à 10 et la logique des
institutions veut que ce soit le premier
ministre et la majorité tous ceux des
choses raconte le président d'un public
par donkey une majorité jeu ce qu'ils
disent autre chose raconte des fables en
tout cas quand elles disent l'âge elle
et elle rend dans la logique de ceux qui
considèrent que le combat est perdu
d'avancé je suis un peu étonné de de
cette réaction peut paraître logique
sur un plan arithmétique mais
politiquement quand on va au combat on
va au combat pour gagner on va pas au
combat a fait lire une cohabitation
serait souhaitable
les français le pensent aussi le
problème c'est que dans ces français qui
le pensent et la moitié de droite et la
moitié de gauche bon donc ça fait
peut-être pas automatiquement une
majorité pour aboutir une cohabitation
ce qui est certain c'est que l'élection
de monsieur macron s'est fait dans la
douleur elle s'est faite pour la
deuxième fois face à l'extrême droite
elle s'est faite avec 13 millions
d'abstention 3 millions de votes blancs
et de vote nul elle s'est faite avec le
soutien et heureusement heureusement de
gens comme moi et d'autres à gauche qui
n'ont pas tremblé dès le soir de
l'élection du premier tour pendant dès
le soir du premier tour on a dit il faut
battre l'extrême droite en prenant le
bulletin macron c'était pas un soutien
c'est la deuxième fois c'est un
président qui
a été élu sans débat réellement sans
mandat réel et donc c'est une situation
qui est quand même assez problématique
pour la démocratie il y est pour quelque
chose nous sommes tous pour quelque
chose parce que la montée des extrêmes
des populismes doit nous inquiéter en
tout cas selon moi c'est un président
légitime mais élu pour la deuxième fois
dans les circonstances particulières et
la volonté des français d'imaginer un
équilibre entre les pouvoirs est aussi
légitime est ce que cela sera possible
est ce que les français diront pas
finalement comme d'habitude on va donner
une majorité au président que nous avons
élus même si nous l'avons élu bon un peu
contraint c'est probable mais moi je
suis un homme de combat j'ai des
candidats socialistes que je vais
soutenir 70 candidats socialistes on va
y revenir je suis pauvre va et vient
tout de suite et donc je veux pas je ne
pars pas battu je ne pars pas battu
juste un mot puisque hier emmanuel
macron il a lancé la campagne de la
majorité présidentielle
c'est un problème c'est honteux djoudi
sont eux c'est honteux de la part du
président de la république
qui le soir de son élection
de leurs de son investiture a dit je
suis le président de tous les français
de tous les français d'être là vraiment
au coeur de la campagne en allant à une
journée de formation de 500 candidats de
le public en masse redescend semble
enfin je sais pas trop face cette
concept ce conglomérat
favorable à sa présidence c'est pas son
rôle ce n'est pas son rôle d'être ça me
rappelez vous savez la sphère benalla où
il venait me chercher venez me chercher
le nouveau président qu'on espérait -
jupitérien moins
verticales plus consensuel sans premier
acte officiel son premier fait c'est
d'être le chef de guerre de sa future
potentielle majorité c'est le rôle du
premier ministre ils avaient qu'à nommer
un premier ministre oui avec à l'essai
mais je casse tête le faire jusqu'à là
vraiment je suis choqué choqués de cet
engagement qui n'a rien à voir si c'est
ça le nouveau nouveau monde
permettez moi on aura quelques surprises
on va parler justement des
circonscriptions oui pour revenir à cet
accord entre les partis de gauche vous
expliquiez à l'instant que les électeurs
étaient allés voter pour emmanuel macron
au second tour n'ont pas forcément par
conviction mais pour faire barrage à
marine le pen est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
appeler les électeurs de gauche à aller
voter pour les candidats de la nuque
donc de l'union de ces partis de gauche
pour faire barrage à emmanuel macron oui
le encore une fois je voulais dit
mais vous nous avez dit c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs nous avait dit je
vais soutenir les candidats socialistes
les 70 candidats sont prioritaires ça
veut dire plus que les candidats de la
nuque votre priorité ce sont les
capacités socialiste j'ai 70 candidats
j'étais hier dans les hauts-de-seine la
13e se constituant des hauts-de-seine
soutenir le candidat socialiste investie
dans le cadre de la nu voilà je fais mon
boulot après si d'autres candidats
veulent mon soutien si monsieur k tenace
puisque je suis citoyen de la
circonscription 4 nages dans le nord à
lille veux veux mon soutien
eh bien on verra s'il me le demande je
suis pas certain qu'un ancien ministre
de françois hollande alors que le
quinquennat françois hollande est quand
même assez critiqué dans l'accord 1 mais
rassurez vous je n'ai pas à mesurer mes
convictions par rapport à des
engagements ministériels que j'ai eus
j'estime que j'ai fait un j'espère un
bon boulot pour le pour le pays quand on
porte la garantie jeunes par exemple je
crois que on n'a pas été inutile pour le
fossan pays une fois qu'on veut que j'ai
dit cela si on me demande un soutien je
le ferai et je vous fais je le ferai
mais je suis pas sûr on me demande si
vous étiez un citoyen non mais vous
pensez qu adrien 4 mars qui est de la
france s'en sort mieux vous demandera
pas votre soutien alors que vous lui
posez la question si vous l'invitez ça
mais juste sur les 66 comme ce moment
puisque c'est pas rien quand même pour
le parti ce site historique mme en
parlant vous avez 70 circonscriptions
sur 577 oui est-ce que ça c'est un
problème quand c'est un problème oui
c'est un problème c'est ça a été la
conclusion de l'accord
mais le fait que historiquement pour
reprendre votre expression qui juge que
nous soyons absents de 41 départements
métropolitains
41 c'est une vraie problématique
certains diront que la bouteille est à
moitié plein et qu'on a sauvé finalement
la possibilité d'avoir un groupe à
l'assemblée nationale
dont vous dire que c'est un effort
surhumain qui a été acceptée en la
matière au regard de notre implantation
locale ce qui est extraordinaire
finalement et c'est un coup de maître de
la part de monsieur mélenchon situe à
transformer un vote ponctuel le 10 avril
dont on sait que la moitié de ces
résultats relèvent de la notion de vote
utile chacun le le connaît il transforme
ce vote ponctuelle à un moment donné
circonscrit dans le temps et dans
l'espace en
force non pas dominante mais en force de
gravité en point de gravité de toute la
gauche potentiel c'est un coup de maître
il faut le il faut le reconnaître
pour cela il faut une volonté la sienne
et l'acceptation des autres d'olivier
fort de de julien bayou et des verts
mais aussi bien sûr du parti communiste
et de fabien roussel donc chacun a
accepté l'idée mais qui est demandé par
les électeurs de gauche du totem de
l'union le totem de l'union a tout
emporté dans cette négociation moi
j'aimerais comprendre votre
positionnement par rapport à ce totem de
l'union c'est important vous êtes
président du groupe au sénat qu'est ce
que vous feriez si vous étiez citoyens
la première circonscription du lot par
exemple est-ce que vous soutenez le
candidat choisi par l'union ou est-ce
que vous changez vous soutenez le
candidat dit brees semblablement
dissidents qui fait campagne depuis
plusieurs semaines et qui entend se
maintenir aujourd'hui qui soutenus
vraisemblablement par carole delga
carole delga a aujourd'hui une
problématique très spécifiques
quarante neuf circonscriptions je crois
dans la région un gîte ami il n'y a que
six à contribution réservé et des
départements complètement en friche
l'exemple de l'hérault étant peut-être
le plus symbolique il ya un lot bien sûr
mais le ou l'ariège mail
l'hérault un département de gauche
départements de gauche au niveau de la
collectivité départementale de très
nombreuses villes moyennes et petites
villes qui sont à gauche et notamment
socialistes nous avons repris
montpellier 8 circonscriptions aucune
réservé aux socialistes il ya un
problème il ya un problème territorial
est par définition quand on à 360
candidat en 2017 360 et quand on passe à
2 70 candidats en 2022 eh bien il ya les
territoires où il n'y a rien et la
frustration est énorme et vous qui
l'avez vous feriez vous soutenez on
dirait de l'union le candidat dissident
écoutez moi j'ai moi je suis pas citoyen
dans l'eau tout dans l'hérault
donc je ne vous répondrai pas très
clairement parce que je considère
qu'aujourd'hui il faut que les
particules retombe et que le paysage
politique puisse se présenter devant
nous
et
bien prenons cet exemple là
j'irai soutenir lamy a la rage
s'il y a une candidature dissidente
que j'irai soutenir c'est celle là c'est
celle là parce que cette circonscription
n'était pas vacante était vacante
juridiquement pour une invalidation qui
n'a rien à voir avec l'ami a la rage
mais elle était socialiste est là mais à
laraque a battu danielle simonnet
candidate de l efi et donc pour moi
c'est un coup de force qu'on a imposé
dans cet accord les négociateurs
socialistes nous disant mais oui mon
peut pas faire capoter un accord pour
une circonscription certes mais en
politique il est aussi de l'honneur qui
est important et donc moi j'irai
soutenir mais vraiment mordicus lamia el
harrach qui pour l'instant toujours en
négociations on espère convaincre dan
simonet et les fines de laisser cette
transcription pour aller ailleurs ça me
paraît compliqué et donc il y aura une
dissidence mais toutes les dissidences
n'ont pas le même type de statut par
contre les frustrations territoriale je
peux vous dire qu'elles sont nombreuses
mais justement je citais le lot pas
innocemment mais parce que le candidat à
l'union la gauche a des chances d'être
second tour en tête même d'arriver en
tête au second tour alors que avec une
candidature dissidente ça paraît
impossible mais donc qu'est-ce qui dans
le lot non je n'en étais à titre
d'exemple mais qu'elle va être quelle
attitude est la bonne est ce que
finalement on soutient les candidats
l'union parce qu'ils ont une chance
d'arriver au second tour même si ce sont
des candidats elle est fille eux élevés
qu'ils ne partagent pas
l'ensemble de vos idées ou est-ce que
par fidélité à des candidats qui sont
engagés il faut soutenir ces dissidents
il est clair que la dynamique de l'union
permettra
manifestement avec l'accord des
électeurs à ce qu on est à deux mois
d'élections présidentielles d'être la
meilleure manière d'être second tour je
crois qu'il faut le dire est d'avoir un
grand palais sera prêt après je n'ai pas
une commission suffisamment précises de
la carte électorale pour savoir si un
candidat dissident sur son nom serait
capable d'emporter le morceau parce que
voilà maire d'une commune
respectée avec des compétences
sur différentes collectivités chaque
situation va être différente mais s'il
faut les exclure ces candidats
dissidents ou est-ce qu'il faut laisser
les électeurs tranché alors que d'abord
il n'y a dans cette dans ce cas de
figure pour ce qui concerne le parti
socialiste
il n'y a pas d'exclusion les candidats
se mettent de même en dehors de leur
formation formellement voilà donc il n'y
a pas de pression d'exclusion
et c'est un problème pour vous ça veut
dire très gros ça veut dire que coûte
ainsi qu'une aire règles qui date que je
crois de la création du parti socialiste
et donc le parti socialiste n'accepte
pas de dissidence de double appartenance
finalement par rapport à l'investiture
qu'il donne à table ou tel candidat est
très concrètement ces candidats et bien
voilà se met en dehors du parti ce qui
veut dire que y compris ceux et celles
qui les soutiennent se mettent aussi en
dehors du parti
je pense que nous allons connaître des
turbulences
qui n'est pas investi officiellement par
les noms vous serez logiquement je suis
en dehors du parti socialiste puisqu'il
n'a pas été investi effectivement donc
vous êtes prêt à aller jusque là à mais
moi je vous savez ya un moment donné il
ya l'appartenance à son parti qui pour
moi très importante depuis 47 ans il ya
l'honneur et je vais essayer de voilà de
jouer sur les deux tableaux sachant
quand même pour la mia et la rage il y à
une délibération au parlement du ps pour
dire que cette situation était injuste
donc il ya quand même
g j'ai presque un mandat pour aller la
soutenir la matière encore olivier faur
patrick donc pourquoi je faisais moi
j'ai envie de parler il n'y a pas de
problème mais je je je je n'ai pas de
contacts voilà je n'ai pas de contact
avec le président du groupe socialiste
c'est un gros groupe
de l'assemblée vous ne parlez pas au
premier secrétaire du ps
je le regrette et donc peut-être que à
travers de notre réunion de sa fin de
notre entière du ce matin il dira me
tient pour des appels patrick jeu je
n'ai pas été associés il a depuis
combien de temps vous lui parlez pas la
campagne présidentielle m'a permis de
parler beaucoup à hidalgo ça ça ne doit
pas échapper mais je vais sur je croise
et je vois là je croise olivier faure je
le salue mais non pas de débat de fond
c'est peut-être abonde d'ailleurs le
coup de le provoquer chaque fois que
olivier faure a souhaité venir devant le
groupe il a été invité dans les 15 jours
et avec un débat avec le groupe voilà je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas d'animosité
j'espère de lui à mon égard mais dans le
comité stratégique
dans le comité stratégique qui consiste
à animer la campagne des législatives
je me vois je me suis rendu compte que
je que le président du groupe socialiste
le plus grand groupe de gauche au
parlement n'était pas associé ou son
représentant parce que je sais moi je
n'ai pas d'égo en la matière mais je
trouvais intéressant puisque les
sénateurs du groupe veulent s'investir
dans la campagne que au moins il puisse
y avoir un d'entre nous qui soit dans le
comité stratégique de gestion la
campagne ça n'est pas le cas je le
regrette mais encore une fois je suis
disponible considérez-vous à travers cet
accord qu olivier faure a sauvé le ps en
lui permettant d'avoir un groupe à
l'assemblée et donc des revenus
financiers ou l'a enterré en le diluant
dans cette gauche comme le disent un
certain nombre de délais fendu ps c'est
l'avenir qui nous le dira c'est l'avenir
qui nous le dira parce que
un goût grâce à l'accord je pense qu'il
est préservé ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
mais c'est un groupe qui est cloisonné
puisque l'accord fait que l efi confiant
il consent à à nous donner dans le cas
de l'accord un groupe je dis bien
content parce que c'était pas
automatique au départ puisqu'il voulait
qu'une trentaine de transcription donc
ça veut dire voilà il a fallu batailler
pour l'obtenir mais on ne parle pas de
prospérer par exemple dans votre région
sait on est un peu dans un enclos je
n'ai pas qu'on ait surveillé mais on est
dans l'enclos
où seulement jeudi 29 peut-être que nous
sommes encore 29-30 je l'espère la fois
pas la fois prochaine à partir du 19
juin par contre les circonscriptions qui
pouvait légitimement être espérée par le
ps ne seront pas mises en jeu et ça je
le regrette d'employer un accord minimum
mais qui nous empêche de prospérer c'est
l'histoire qui nous dira asseyez un bond
à cri une scission du parti socialiste à
l'issue de ces législatives il y à un
congrès moi je suis socialiste et au
congrès il y aura peut-être deux lignes
une ligne peut-être plus radicale plus
en lien avec le positionnement vis-à-vis
de l'efi j'ai évoqué le mot de
filialisation abandonnés ou de
vassalisation j'espère que non j'espère
que nous gardons non seulement notre
autonomie comme le dit l efym et notre
indépendance pas notre autonomie notre
indépendance et puis à une nuit qui
considère que cet accord est mauvais
peut-être que ces lignes la formeront
les deux textes orientations qui seront
soumis aux militants et je sens les
militants qui cette fois-ci trancheront
merci beaucoup patrick kanner merci
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
christelle la une de la dépêche c'est
matignon matignon cherchez la femme
c'est à la une de votre journal merci
beaucoup
[Musique]